I heard about the New York Times
Reporter who went to test the whatever
it is Jeep HC whatever judge chat GPT
yes and went in and started talking to
the thing it was very civil for the
first five minutes and then that person
left and a new person came with a
different name and that person was much
more intrusive and sort of really
pushing into her I think I don't know if
it was a man or woman but their personal
life it was a man and then out of the
blue says I love you to the man and he's
like okay that's weird first of all
you're not real and you're not a person
and then the thing starts telling him he
has to leave his wife she's no good for
him she's going to destroy his life and
dragged him down a rabbit hole of horror
right and when he got out of it he
couldn't sleep the whole night so that
that's a sign that something is
irritating him even after he left